last time I trusted someone I lost an
eye
hey everybody it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Captain Marvel review I'll try to
keep it as spoiler free as possible but
I'll talk about how she fits into the
MCU what they did with her story that
makes it different from other Marvel
origin stories like Captain America the
First Avenger or the first Iron Man film
it held will they established her in the
universe going into Avengers endgame
because this movie is sort of like the
palate cleanser between infinity war
that huge downer ending everybody
getting turned to dust in the big epic
conclusion to the first era of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in Avengers
endgame we'll do a new round of the IMAX
ticket giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment about the movie on the video
I'll name a new winner at the end of
this so what was the tone like how was
it different from other Marvel origin
story movies it felt a little bit like a
Top Gun memento Christopher Nolan
memento Superman style movie it is
probably the most non traditional
version of an origin story that they've
ever tried in the movie Captain America
the First Avenger as an origin story is
a good comparison because he starts out
with a military background just like
Carol Danvers regular guy does
everything he can to fight for what he
believes is right tries to do it all day
I could do this all day despite being
told by everyone else that he's
physically too frail you're too weak you
get yourself hurt we can't allow you to
do this until he gets a little help from
science in the Super Soldier Serum
program thank you very much Howard Stark
and dr. Erskine they give him the
physical strength to match his big heart
his courage the funny thing about Carol
Danvers though is that she's there's a
little more in common with T'Challa in
some of the ways that the Black Panther
movie used that character he starts out
in that movie as a total badass but then
sort of has to find his way as a leader
and emerges at the end of the tunnel in
even bigger badass so Carol Danvers
starts out in the top gun of it all
she's already a really badass Air Force
pilot they don't let just anybody become
Air Force pilots so just like Black
Panther she starts out really strong in
at various points in the movie is tested
in that she doesn't know if she's going
to be able to be strong enough to do
what she needs to do but eventually
because it's a superhero movie they're
relatively optimistic about things she
finds the strength within herself and
becomes the superhero Captain Marvel
that you'll eventually see during
avengers endgame punching everyone in
sight the thing that really sets her
apart from say like Thor
and Iron Man origin stories or even like
ant-man or Doctor Strange is that
they're all incredibly talented people
to begin with but some of the more
traditional phase one phase two Avengers
are held back by egos or severe
narcissism like Iron Man tragic events
usually cause them to re-examine their
lives and put their talents to better
use there really aren't that many
moments where you see Carol Danvers
Captain Marvel or black panther for that
matter being relatively self-centered or
egocentric they're two characters
saddled with insurmountable odds in this
crazy problem that they have to solve
and they have to slug their way through
it the real twist enos of it all that a
lot of people I've seen are having
problems with coming out of the movie
they just kind of throws them for a loop
because it's not something you would
expect from a traditional Marvel
superhero film is the Christopher Nolan
memento of it all like I made that
reference Top Gun memento Superman so if
you haven't seen Christopher Nolan's
memento is this very first feature film
it's a great film but a lot of it is the
protagonist trying to piece together his
past and largely that's what Captain
Marvel does through the course of her
film in fact you could call that the
main plot of the film there's a lot of
other big stuff happening but it doesn't
feel quite as important or central to
what's happening in the film as is her
quest to rediscover who she really is
so that's why it feels so different from
other Marvel films because typically
like in an Iron Man film there is a
villain that's trying to do something
really terrible that the hero has to
stop in in Captain Marvel it's more of
an inward journey to try and see through
all the gas lighting that she's been
getting from all the other characters
I'm a big fan of a lot of the 90s films
that they referenced during this they
call it like a Robocop film in the way
that he has to rediscover his memories
when he becomes Robocop oh this is who I
used to be before I became this crazy
machine there are times when she does
feel a lot like The Terminator character
so there are a couple confusing action
scenes and some of her motivation can be
a little confusing at times of all the
Marvel characters though I would say
early on in the movie her personality is
most like Thor's you know very impulsive
very trigger-happy Punch old ladies
first ask questions later kind of
behavior but one of the big surprises of
the movie is is that it feels so
different from the movie that we got
just looking at the trailers so I did
think that they had a problem marketing
the film just because of the momento
aspect of it all like the fact that it's
so twisty and it doesn't move like
traditional Marvel Cinematic Universe
movie if you watch the trailers and felt
like brie Larson didn't seem very
expressive during those or didn't have a
lot of emotions none of that was in the
movie so I have no idea what was going
on a lot of those trailers she's
actually really good during the movie
she's an oscar-winning actress in the
directors or great indie film directors
that specialize in developing characters
so actually a lot of the criticisms that
I had of the movie and that I've seen a
lot of other people have in common are
largely technical things like the way
they edited their bigger action scenes
some bad lighting and some of the
crazier scenes all those things I think
are just a result of a couple of indie
film directors doing their very first
huge hundred and fifty million dollar
superhero movie so no big surprise there
the usual trade-off you get going with
indie directors for movies this big or
that they're amazing when it comes to
the really personal character work and I
do think they did a great job in
combination with brie Larson's
performance of the character and
bringing a much more complex female
character that doesn't necessarily have
to lean on a lot of the tropi superhero
plot devices but on the minus side indie
directors who have never done big action
movies before just aren't quite as
experienced at orchestrating huge
infinity war levels special effects
fights or massive CG sequences so it
does show you where Kevin Feige is
prioritizing all of his energy clearly
more focused on developing the character
Captain Marvel than he was on delivering
big infinity war level action because
you're gonna get that during avengers
endgame while i say that the movie does
have some really cool big action scenes
it also tries to undercut some of those
superhero landing trophy moments you've
already seen a million other times in
the Marvel movies when she goes full
binary Super Saiyan Captain Marvel they
try to make it feel very different from
scenes like Thor powering up or like
Thor entering Wakanda still one of the
best scenes from infinity war in ben
mendelsohn and Sam Jackson just to start
talking about the actors performances
the de-aging effect on samuel l.jackson
is so good you'll forget that he's 70
years old in real life he's got great
buddy cop chemistry with brie Larson's
Captain Marvel he's also as you would
expect the more comedic character of the
two which is made even more funny
because you know how stone-cold Sirius
Avengers era Nick Fury is in present day
I really hope they bring him back in the
Captain Marvel sequel they supposedly
say that it's going to be said during
present day so that should be a little
bit easier but it would have to be a
post Avengers endgame Nick Fury Allah
spider-man far from home so we'll see
about that in a couple months and Ben
Mendelsohn's performance underneath all
those scroll prosthetics is amazing he's
having so much fun in this movie in
terms of creature performance just
because there's so much scroll makeup on
him he is Andy Serkis level good he
seems like he's having way more fun in
the movie than most of the other
characters Allah Loki but that tends to
be the way you go with more playful
villains in the MCU he enjoys every
minute of it so he's got some great
action scenes too even when he's not in
scroll makeup remember Scrolls can
change into other people they use that
to great effect during the movie they
did a great job with the scrolls just in
general they lay the seeds for a much
wider scroll presence in the MCU in
future movies and one thing you do not
get from any of the trailers it's just
how cosmic the movie goes they do a
great job of world building in outer
space hopefully they can pick up on some
of that during future MCU movies like
Nova or a quasar or any other
space-based franchises that they want to
do there's also this whole untapped
history of the MCU in outer space that
we haven't seen yet you get a better
sense from that after you see the movie
the Eternals movie will also be a really
good example that do not be surprised
after this movie if they do more space
based movies set during the past they do
a really good job of redeeming Lee paces
Ronan the accuser in Korath obviously
much younger versions of the character
there wasn't quite enough Jemma Chan min
irva in the movie for my liking but she
was pretty fun she's a great actress she
just wasn't around for quite as much as
I expected and even though I had a
pretty good idea of what the movie was
gonna be doing with Jude Law's character
both he and Lee paces Ronan the accuser
surprised me a little bit with some of
the story twists in the way that they
used them and that Bening plays multiple
characters she was great in both of her
roles no surprise there but she was also
very important to Carol Danvers
backstory and who she winds up being in
present day gusta cat steals most of the
scenes that he's in he has a lot of
funny moments if you've read the comics
there's some really big payoffs that
pull from the Captain Marvel comics and
there are two post-credits scenes a
mid-credits scene and a legit
post-credits scene so stay through all
the credits it's the last movie before
Avengers end game of course you should
stay through the entire credits and
don't worry I will do a separate video
for the post-credits scenes later this
week the Stan Lee cameo was hilarious
and because this is a 90s
it winds up being a super meta reference
if you've watched a lot of the 90s
movies that this movie is pulling from a
lot of the references that it makes I
can't say more about it without
completely giving it away but as someone
who has watched most of the 80s and the
90s films that they referenced during
the film it was higher on my list of
favorite Stan Lee cameos my favorite one
is still watcher Stan Lee from guardians
of the galaxy to Kevin Feige he also did
confirmed that Stan Lee has shot his
cameos for Avengers endgame in
spider-man far from home so he will
appear during those movies to your
milage on the soundtrack will vary just
depending on how you feel about 90s
music in general particularly angry girl
band 90s music there were only one or
two poor song choices for big record
drop moments but otherwise I thought the
music was great the very specific female
centric story beats that they hit
character beats weren't too heavy-handed
if you're not a woman they probably
won't resonate with you as much but they
will completely take you out of the film
and I'd say ranking it amongst other
Marvel films in general I'd say solid
mid-level MCU in terms of quality
performance enjoyment and re-watch
ability it does a good job of being
completely different than any Marvel
movie you've seen before while also
being light enough that you could
consider it a palate cleanser after the
downer ending an infinity war and
getting you excited for Avengers endgame
so as a film it's a good proof of
concept for the character giving her
common points of history tying her
origin story to other big Avengers
characters that I'll talk about during
my Easter eggs video introducing new
concepts like the scrolls and showing
you why she as a character is so
important to earth and the Avengers
during avengers endgame so once you have
a chance to see the movie just let me
know what you thought of it in the
comments below my post credit scene
video and my Easter eggs should post in
the next couple of days leave any
special requests or big questions you
want me to make videos about in the
comments
congratulations living laser you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details click here to rewatch the Game
of Thrones season 8 trailer a billion
more times and click here to learn about
all the Marvel movies coming after
Avengers endgame thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]